jane bieber will be our nissan starting
pitcher for the indians this afternoon
and he is 6-0 120 era we showed you all
the numbers he leads the world in
strikeouts and everything else there's
nobody pitching better in major league
baseball than shane bieber
and he'll have four lefties in the
lineup today including this man ben
gamel
swinging in a mess he overpowered him
with a good fastball and bieber with
strikeout number 85 and 53 innings of
work kesten hera riding a six-game
hitting streak
to third
maybe a tough play for ramirez he gets
to throw away and what a job oh baby oh
what a sensational play
ramirez deeper third going to the line
with a backhand and a jump throw to get
kissed in hiro that's as good a play as
any third baseman can make he spun and
got off a perfect high arcing throw to
nab here for out number two you will
never see a better play than the one
right here and that is out number two
and here's christian yelich comes back
to it man good night one two three go to
the brewers bieber strikes out a pair
and jose ramirez turns in one of the
best plays you'll see here's brett
anderson making his seventh start yeah
good numbers against the indians look at
that 4-0
carlos santana batting right-handed
drills one to left down the line it goes
into the corner ramirez will score
santana on his way to second with an rbi
double and the indians take a
one-nothing lead here in inning number
one grandma reyes the batter the
designated hitter eight home runs in 25
rbis on the season
this one to short arcia
and there's your final out but the
indians score first daniel bogle back
and here's the 2-2 pitch
and it's swung on drill to left and back
goes luplow and reaches up and made the
catch here's orlando arcel
beaver strikes him out third k for shane
two down here in the second inning here
is luis urias the pitch
and strike three called he took a
fastball so shane bieber has made 30
pitches through two innings peterson
first round pick by san diego 10 years
ago out of mcneese state
got him looking
breaking ball top of the zone peterson
hopping mad tyron taylor making his
first career start
and that didn't take long six strikeouts
for bieber that's four in orono add
another one to the three three pitch
strikeout jacob nottingham the
right-handed hitting catcher here's the
2-2
swing in a miss he chased the slider in
the dirt and bieber strengths out the
side he has seven strikeouts and is
perfect through three
the pitch and vogelback rips it into
right field for a base hit
yelich is around second he's gonna try
to go first to third here's the throw
it's not in time and the brewers have
him on the corners with two outs first
hit of the game comes off the bat of dan
vogelback his fourth hit as a brewer in
just three games so with a runner at
third and two down jordan luclo to the
plate
oh what a job by luplow inside out just
punches it down the right field line and
the two out rbi single delivers
francisco lindor from third two nothing
cleveland
and this one down the right field line
of base hit and harris will stay at
first here's jace peterson 3-2 on the
way and this one laced in the right
field another base hit marias takes
third and milwaukee making their biggest
threat against bieber in this game two
aboard nobody out tyrone taylor the
batter the one-two swing and a miss
strike three
he got him with a breaking ball and that
is a huge strikeout for bieber runners
at first and third for milwaukee now one
down for nottingham here's the one two
and this one up the middle and it's
fumbled everybody's going to be safe and
the brewers are going to get their first
run of the game
2-1 pitch and gamble the other way into
left field for a base hit everybody
moves up 90 feet the bases are loaded
and one away but now the bases are
loaded with one out and kesten hira will
step in one of the hottest hitters for
milwaukee bieber's in the dog fight now
here's the 2-2 to hear him
swing at a miss strike three tremendous
strikeout for bieber at a key moment
it's his ninth in the game and now
there's two down in the inning but the
inning not done yet christian yelich the
batter bieber looking for the ground
ball to get out of the inning 302 swing
and a miss he struck him out and shane
bieber gets out of a mess by striking
out two brewers with the bases loaded
he's punched out 10 today
bieber went five innings he allowed a
run on four hits walk one struck out tim
and after 103 pitches he gives way to
phil maton
swung on hit high in the air fairly deep
center mercado drifting back he's got it
and maton works out of the jam
[Applause]
deep left field yelling back he's on the
track at the wall he can't make the play
around second on his way to third is
ramirez and into second with a double is
lindor carlos santana one for two with
an rbi double
santana swings in a 3-0 pitch and lines
it into left field past the diving arcia
and the indians tacked on a run as
ramirez scores
slowly chopped to short they'll go to
second for one on to first they get the
double play the indians get another run
and it's four to one
3-2 to arcia
he had to reach for it in between lindor
trying to great play he did it oh my
francisco lindor
with a spectacular defensive gem both he
and ramirez today have made a couple of
outstanding plays one and two the gun is
nottingham
ground ball in the hole lindor's there
onto first yes double play game over
brad hand nails it down and the indians
win the series taking two out of three
from milwaukee
save number 11 for brad hand
and the indians win it by a final count
of four to one they're gonna take a peek
at it too
yeah that's close just don't mean that
there's enough to overturn it
um i don't think it's gonna get
overturned that was close he's still out
he's he's gone so officially that's the
ball game